[Music]
now why did i do that
[Music]
when people evaluate great actors what
often gets mentioned
most is range how many different
characters they can play how many
different
emotions they can realistically movingly
show
but i think a criterion that's just as
telling as range
is depth how many different ways an
actor can portray
the same emotion i spent the last few
weeks watching pretty much every film
jack nicholson ever made and it's clear
that the man
can do it all but it's also no mistake
that intensity
is his calling card today i'd like to
explore the ways that jack nicholson
conveys
and uses anger in his work the angles he
approaches it from
the spins and emphasises he puts on it
in order to see what makes jack
nicholson so
great
[Music]
anger is an emotional response a
reaction to something
that reaction manifests psychologically
but also
physically everyone's had that sensation
of being
convulsed with anger what nicholson
shows again
and again in his roles is how anger can
literally possess
the body like a spirit because i really
want to know
because if it's a mistake maybe we could
do something about it
this is the moment when anger becomes
aggression
half the time that aggression and
nicholson's work is realized as
actual violence against someone else
whether it's
psychotic violence or in some way
justified
the other half of the time this
theatrical anger takes place
in nicholson's own personal space he
flails around sometimes
as a threat or a suggestion of violence
to come a lot of the time it's just
a release a discharge of pent-up energy
to me these moments the weird
contortions and spasms that nicholson
makes are more
poignant than actual attacks on people
they're a kind of
exploration of the relationship between
body and mind
and it never feels like overacting i
think that's because
these gesticulations are all unique to
the particular
anger that they spring from whether it's
focused
pointed anger or generally frustrated
anger or
petulant childlike anger you see that
sign sir
yes you all have to leave i'm not taking
any more of your smartness and sarcasm
you see this sign
for nicholson and everybody else for
that matter anger can be a form of
desperation a noise
so loud that you don't have to hear your
own insecurities
in mike nichols carnal knowledge for
example nichols plays a playboy who
objectifies women and refuses to commit
one of his lovers asks him to get
married and he explodes where the [ __ ]
is my shoehorn this place is a mess
there's not any food in the house half
the time you look like you fell out of
bed
nicholson acts a kind of anger here that
it's easy to see right through
the larger and louder it is the closer
he is to recognizing a vulnerability
in himself you want an extra fifty
dollars a week try
vacuuming you want an extra hundred make
this goddamn bed
try only some goddamn windows that's why
you can't stand up in here the goddamn
place smells like a coffin
that's the challenge for an actor
playing this emotion you're not just
playing
anger you're playing what's under it
most anger isn't
psychotic it's only a thin veneer for
what's brewing below and you have to be
able
to turn up the volume while preserving
traces of this deeper motivation
that's what nicholson excels at in the
border for example nicholson plays a
border agent who gets caught up with his
partner's human smuggling operation
when the partner starts killing his
competition nicholson realizes
that he's gotten in too far the key
emotion in this exchange
isn't anger but fear fear at what he's
gotten himself into
fear that he won't be able to get
himself out nicholson bursts with anger
here but it's
in the silent moments where the actual
feelings lie
i don't care about your [ __ ] money
but you too [ __ ] life is gonna be fly
[ __ ] before i ever get involved murder
you understand what i'm saying to you
do you this is why nicholson's
characters seem real in their anger even
with great writing and great direction
it's only the actor who can make a
character polyphonic like more than one
thing is happening
at the same time and even when you do
that the particular expression of anger
has to rise out of the particular
character's personality
for example take these two examples of
anger which are both
underlaid with a strong sense of
superiority you can't handle the truth
son we live in a world that has walls
and those walls have to be guarded by
men with guns who's gonna do it
you you lieutenant weinberg never
never interrupt me okay
not if there's a fire not even if you
hear the sound of a thud from my home
and one week later
there's a smell coming from there that
can only be a decaying human body
and you have to hold a hanky to your
face because the stench is so thick that
you think you're gonna faint
both of these men feel smarter and more
important than the person they're
lecturing to but the first
is a lifelong military man in a court of
law nicholson barely moves his body or
head every
swivel of the neck is measured and exact
he's so restrained that a simple lean
forward feels like he's lost it i did
the job did you order the code
you're goddamn right i did the second
man
is smug and in his own space his
movements
are freer looser and they even seem to
mock greg kinnear's homosexuality
don't knock not on this store
not for any reason
do you get me sweetheart no two
expressions of anger are the same not in
real life
and not nicholson's work sometimes his
anger is comedic
sometimes cartoonish sometimes it's
quiet
sometimes it's misplaced and sometimes
it's deeply deeply wounded
whatever you're doing stop it freddy
whatever you're doing
stop it
i hope you die i hope you
[ __ ] die watching so much of
nicholson's acting you start to get a
sense
of the larger shape of anger as a human
phenomenon
its extremes its physicality and its
dangers
but also its necessity in the course of
a life
none of us can avoid anger you can't
remove it from the constellation of
feelings
but you can't understand it jack
nicholson has a wide
range of talents as wide a range as an
actor as anybody else
and yet if all he ever did was give us
these
60 years of insights into anger
it would still be a career well spent
hey everybody thanks for watching that
was a lot of jack nicholson movies to
see uh but it was totally worth it you
learn a lot by watching a master uh
thanks for watching that and thank you
to the great courses plus for sponsoring
this video if you don't know what it is
the great courses plus is an on-demand
video learning service
which basically means it's got over 7
000 online video lecture series
from some great ivy league professors
and other professors
about all kinds of subjects math and
history and archaeology
but one that i think meshes with what we
were just talking about with acting
is this course by daniel robinson called
the great ideas in psychology
sort of which go all along the history
of psychology to
to overview what's been talked about and
discovered and
that's sort of my wheelhouse so i love
to learn that kind of stuff
check that out if you go to
thegreatcoursesplus.com
nerdwriter you can get a 30 day free
trial you can find that
as the first link in the description
down there after that it's 14.99 a month
i think it's really cool if you like
learning i think you'd really love it
thanks guys for watching and i will see
the rest of you next wednesday